[Music]
is there an external reality of course
there's an external reality the world
exists it's just that we don't see it
these we don't see as it is in fact we
can never see it at incidence in fact
it's even useful to not see it it is and
the reason is because it goes back to
really Berkeley who told us we have no
direct access to that physical world
other than through our senses and
because our senses conflate multiple
aspects of that world we can never know
whether our perceptions are in any way
accurate and so this has always been a
very deep question it's not so much do
we see the world in the way that really
is but do we actually even see it
accurately and the answer is no we don't
so the if we remember that the
information that's coming on to your eye
or onto your skin or into your ears is
inherently meaningless because it could
mean anything then it means that we need
another kind of data in order to be able
to generate behaviors that are useful
and that data is necessarily historical
which means that the functional
structure of your brain is really a
physical manifestation of your past
interactions with the world and it's a
physical active interaction it's not a
passive receiving data like a Facebook
broadcast is an active engagement with
that world so for instance if you take
there's a well-known experiment back in
the 70s where you had two kittens
recently born eyes just opened and you
had one kitten that was effectively
running on the ground I perfectly fine
and you had another one that was in a
basket and the one in the basket was
connected to one on the ground which
meant that wherever the one in the
basket went it was because it was aware
the one on the ground also went the
point is that they had the same visual
history of the world then after a period
of time you test the vision of the one
on the ground and it seems fine as you
would expect but the question is what
does the one in the basket see and the
answer is that it doesn't see anything
it's blind because it's never been able
to physically engage with the sources of
this meaning
information and make meaning from it so
then when you let it run around it
learns to see you again now sometimes
it's really difficult for people to
understand that the data that your brain
is receiving is meaningless because when
they open eyes they look around and say
why I see everything what do you mean
it's meaningless so a really simple
example in fact is possibly one of the
most fundamental example is color so
actually if you think about the what
they call dress gate and the power of
that
well I found really remarkable because
we're all familiar with illusions and
we're all quite happy with the idea that
someone who is a French speaker has a
different word different meanings than
someone who's an English speaker because
we're quite happy that things that are
very cultural or in our own experience
we can experience differently we can
have different concepts but as soon as
people realize that you can have
different coloured perceptions that
really challenge them because it means
if that's true what does it mean for the
perception of reality right so colour is
a wonderful concept because it's both
very literal and abstract and what's
true for colour is true for everything
about what we see so take for instance
what is the source of our perception of
colour it's light and it's light from
four to seven or nanometers which is
actually a very tiny window of the
electromagnetic radiation right so even
at that point we're seeing a tiny window
within the potential energy that we
could in theory detect what's more
that's a linear scale from four December
from small to large but our perception
of color which starts with light is
anything but simple in fact it's a
three-dimensional perceptual space
inside our head so for instance you have
a brightness axis which is intensity you
have a saturation axis which is how much
gray is in the color so a fire engine is
very unsaturated or rather a very
saturated red and a pink is a relatively
unsaturated red has gray in it and then
you have hue which is red green blue and
yellow what's remarkable is that the two
ends of the spectrum the physical
spectrum say short wavelengths which we
perceive to be violet and blue
and the other end of the spectrum which
we perceive to be red are actually
perceptually more similar to each other
than they are to the middle part of the
spectrum which means that our
perceptions color is a circle which
means the largest and the smallest
stimuli are actually perceptually
similar to each other which is like one
kilo feeling a lot like a thousand kilos
and very different from 500 kilos so
even at that most basic level what we're
seeing is not what's actually even in
the stimulus what's more is our
perception of color is categorical you
can define every color in terms of red
green blue and yellow and each category
is defined by what we call unique cue a
processional redness that has no other
hue in it whereas orange you can
perceive sort of a combination of red
and yellow but with red you only see red
yellow you only see yellow but there's
nothing unique about spectra there's
nothing categorical about spectra
they're continuous distributions so at
this most basic level we don't represent
even the information we're getting in
any accurate way and the reason is
because it was useful to see it this way
so we've seen the utility of the data
not the data
you